hey guys Ryan right over here so I have
an idea for a channel trailer right
before I'm about to take off I wanted to
throw this out there since we're almost
at a hundred thousand subscribers I
would like to get this channel trailer
up around the day we hit a hundred
thousand subscribers but I need your
guys's help to do this for the channel
trailer what I want to do is do a
compilation of fans talking about the
real rejects so if you guys since you
all have YouTube accounts if you guys
can shoot a quick video it could be on
your phone it could be on a camera
whatever you want you can upload it to
your account and then send me the video
link at real rejects fan base at
gmail.com real rejects fan base at
gmail.com send it in and I'm gonna do a
compilation video of all the fans who
send one end talking about the real
rejects you can say whatever you want as
long as it's complimentary just say it
okay and yeah they'll be taking
submissions until we're at ninety nine
thousand nine hundred subscribers so in
the meantime I'll be waiting for your
videos